[Music]
hello everyone i'm grand master dennis
boris
and this is games of the week and
well there are many things happening
this
month and dream this september
this is october 1st of course um
so we had the protest league with
the archbishops claiming the title once
again
but apart from that there was bundesliga
with a cornish gentleman
player from cornwall and
his name is michael adams some of you
might
have not heard of him he was actually a
very nice upcoming british
champion one of those first prodigies
who made it to the top in the 90s
among many others like kramnik ivanchuk
among them was adams mickey adams
as everybody calls him
he is oftentimes called spider-man
for his subtle positional
style however what's fascinating
in this week's event is that he win
and beat five grand masters in a row
consecutively
in the championship to help baden madden
win the title now we're going to take a
few
take a look at a few of those games
played by
mickey adams first off the game i want
to
show you guys is adam's facing off
versus the petrov so let's jump right in
into this game versus atoms playing
smeats e4 e5
knight f3 knight f6 everyone's favorite
line
apart from the berlin the petrov defense
so this was
some sort of a rare guest in the
80s and 90s however
if you followed the world championship
matches between
karpov and kasparov you might have seen
lots of karo khans
and the russian defense aka the petrov
now it again had a renaissance when we
had the world championship match just
recently
between fabiano corona and magnus
carlsen
the reigning world champion where corona
was at the time
that survive on scat playing this
opening
it's a very sound opening that's why the
russians
loved playing it but enough history
lesson
let's jump into the game d6
now you might have seen
dear friend reviewing
the fantastic game between
krishuk and karwana where queen d7
was a big novelty and eventually the
game that clinched the ticket for corona
for the world championship match
here knight takes e5 happened d6
knight f3 i take c4 d4 and this is
actually the main line
that has been played multiple times
and has featured in the world
championship match between kasparov
and karpov with karpov playing the
petrov
and kasparov as saying one e4
d5 bishop d3 bishop d6
by the way there are plenty of moves
here
and i was younger so much younger than
today
i actually tried out ideas of bishop f5
and guess what this became super popular
recently again
white has the isolated queen pawn
structure
but it does give some lively play as
usually
iqp structures do but the main main line
here
is knight c6 castle bishop e7
c4 knight b4 and this has even
been played in another world
championship match between
laco and kramnik the first game which
one is
famous for black winning that one
and then progressing to have a tough
struggle
in that match where leko actually had a
chance
to claim the world championship title
but
at the last moment kramnik did stop him
anyways talking about kramnik bishop d6
was his favorite move which is less
defensive
should be seven knight c6 is more of a
defensive system
bishop d6 is more like i'm gonna fight
you kind of system castle castle
and originally c4 was the main line with
queen c2
knight a6 a3 f5
and this was one of the patent ideas of
buddies gal fund another world
championship challenger
so anytime you want to see
anyone involved in the world
championship match just
check out a petrov game
now let's talk again a bit about mickey
adams
mickey adams likes playing critical
lines
but he likes it his way the spider-man
way
he doesn't really look for like the best
of the best solutions
but he is trying to positionally
outmaneuver his opponents
so they go rook e1 the point being
he is trying to put some pressure on
that knight
we should have five
in here he actually came up with a move
that's been seen in bishop e7 knight c6
structures
but haven't really been seen in this
specific one
let's think about that how else can
white
try to get an advantage in this type of
position
now c4 is the typical way of going about
it
but there is one second one
before we reveal it
to your viewers try to find your own
solutions
in fact some of the times i did see
knight d2 played in similar structures
saying
that yes we do exchange lots of pieces
however at the end of the day you still
have weak pawns
on d5 and b7 and also
you occasionally have jumps
of knight g5 targeting the h7 pawn
so even though this looks ridiculous
it actually might work however the big
question is whether rook
e8 can stop
the pressure on the knight
and probably does and that's why it's
not played however
mickey adams did come up with the other
move of knight c3
this is a typical move when the bishop
is on e7
not as well known when the bishop is on
d6
and this is by no accident it's
actually a novelty i take c3
b takes c3 bishop takes d3
in this sense it's kind of difficult to
play against the petrov
because it requires a very good
positional understanding
b a good understanding of dynamics
now if we think about the previous
solution
and idea that we had at knight d2 we
might consider
taking on d3 and this is a move that we
usually see
in these type of positions however
chess principles are there for a reason
and c takes d3 is no wonder
play it because if you can take towards
the center
you should and in fact
this has two concepts intertwined with
it
it taken takes control of the e4 and c4
square
but also sets up a very neat little
idea what could that be
so at the moment white has a slight bit
of an advantage
not a whole bunch it's not a lot
but it is still endurant because white
has so many pawns in the center and
black only has
one pawn sitting on d5
well c takes d3 actually set up the idea
of
queen b3 kind of eyeing the b7 pawn and
the d5 one
now black has lots of tactics here
working
in his favor so it's not winning or
anything
like that but it will put a hefty
amount of pressure on black's position
rookie 8
again trying to vacuum off the board
vacuum off all these pieces rook takes
e8
takes e8 queen b3 notice
that white's concept hangs on a thread
queen e1 is almost checkmate not for
that knight
guarding that square
also queen e2 possibly just bishop e3
making sure that there are no sneaky
business
on the back rank and then you can gobble
gobble those pawns on b7 and d5
queen c6 c4
now usually we don't like double pawns
and that's the way mickey adams feels as
well
you don't want to have double pawns but
you can use them
as a weapon in this scenario
the c2 pawn now turned into d-pawn
is quite ready to capture back on c4
getting a positional advantage
black is a little bit lagging behind
space
and has to deal with moves such as c5 or
d5 which both seem very annoying
and because of this pawn storm and
pawn hedge on d4 and c4 white should be
at least slight bit better
so smith decides to avoid that and plays
knight
d7 saying if you take on d5
fine bay as you will
these guys are tripled and they're going
to
fall so wouldn't really be
too worrying and that
something that he'd said he'd live with
that for sure
but here comes mickey adams
england's best player
of the 90s and 2000s and comes up with a
very
very very nice positional idea
so it seems that white is running out of
steam
and mostly because it seems that black
is about to consolidate
rookie 8 and releasing tension
in the center however
if you're in doubt always
try to gain space
so dear viewers try to look for a move
which grabs a bit more space and
fixes a bit of a target in
black's position
and here the big move is a4
seemingly innocuous but that is kind of
the style
of mickey atoms you think that nothing's
really happening
but slowly and surely you're running out
of
oxygen that is the typical style
of atoms between b6 are we going to
exchange
queens no way jose says
atoms queen c6 a5 now not only did
mickey get that extra space now there's
a target on b7
and d5 and if you're familiar
with chess literature and what you need
to win a chess game
you might run into this term two
weaknesses in a position and if you have
your opponent and create two weaknesses
in your opponent's position
you have all the means to win the game
we clearly
have our sights on b7 and d5 so
atoms has everything ready
to fight for an advantage h6
h3 these are the little grand master
moves
black is just creating a luft for the
king takes away the g5 square
and white does exactly the same thing
he's not going to commit with this
bishop just yet
he doesn't know if he wants to put the
bishop on d2 or e3
so he's waiting he's waiting for black
to show
his intentions rookie 8
oh so you want to invade the e file
well then i'm gonna play bishop e3
no passana says the bishop
knight f6 and critical position number
two
the first critical position was when
mickey adams decided to go a4a5
and just clamp down on the b7 pawn
however again it's crunch time
and white has to decide what should be
the biggest target in the position the
d5 pawn
the b7 pawn who knows
these are the little things that super
grandmasters
think about
definitely white could consider ideas of
rook b1
just get your rook on the open file or
be
a little bit more direct and
more direct mickey adams was played c5
clamping down the structure making sure
this active bishop is condemned to a
worse
square on f8 or e7 smeads chose
bishop e7 so it can be useful in the
defenses
a6
creating a target on a7
so white actually chose a6 fixing this
spawn
saying in the long term if my knight
ever gets to c6
that pawn will be a weakness and if i
win that one
my a pawn is very close to promoting now
if black decides to take now
yes black has
a nicer structure than white but these
spawns on a7 and c7 are just much
weaker and easier to reach
so here fight is practically winning
with adam's pieces
just swarming the whole board
so b6 was sort of a must by smith
rook c1
if you close off the a file i can play
on the c
file queen a8 not a happy move to make
you don't want to misplace your queen
like that
but sweets felt like that's a must
bishop f4 rook c8
queen a4 c6
and even though black does play
positionally soundly so the structure is
nice
but it feels like that queen
is taking upon the role of a lemming
sort of throwing itself off the cliff
b4 it really shouldn't
so that queen is really really badly
plays there
c6 actually makes the situation much
worse
and cb6 is actually a very strong move
saying hey my position is
so good my a pawn is so
strong you have a target on c6 i am
even willing to take on b6 just to
pinpoint that
probably smeads thought that he could
get away with this type of position
and he'll have enough time to reorganize
with a rook
d8907 if he can get b5 in
but adams is going to be very precise
here
and goes full throttle to the most
challenging option yes ctx b6
isn't positionally sound but works
in this specific scenario a b
knight e5 pressure on the pawn
combined with threats of a7 b5
queen a2
should d8 a7 bishop b6
queen a7 and before you know it do you
think
that black could get loose
and could loosen the grip it's over
because knight takes c6
you can go to b6 because you get
captured
bishop d4 obviously doesn't work because
queen takes rook takes
and knight d4 and here
black decided just to give up
because he has no way of escaping
this bishop on a7 so what did
adams do right in this game a he built
a new concept build a good central
control
b he put pressure on the queen side and
c
he acted resolutely when it counted the
most
so this was a game number one adam smith
and let's take a look at game number two
between fedorovsky and
mickey adams
this game actually features
a sicilian played by
fedorovsky sort of
inviting atoms to play a sharp
smashnikov
again something very topical these days
but adams likes the slow grind
and goes for bishop b5 g6
castle bishop g7 and
in the world championship matches
between carlson and caruana
we've seen lots of bishop takes c6d
takes
c6 games d3 queen c7
etc etc with very
much positional maneuvering
however adams would like to have
his own debate so he goes c3 here
c3 is actually looking from a different
perspective
in this type of position saying i'm not
interested in giving up my bishop for
your structure
deficiencies i am going to build a
center of my own
right f6 followed rook e1 castle
d4 d5 just counter attacking
e5 knight e4 bishop e3
just both stirring the center takes
c takes f6 now
f6 does deserve a special mention
now f6 is a good move when
you are struggling for space like in the
french
or in these rossolimo type of positions
however from a positional standpoint
it is somewhat dubious as
it creates disruption between your
pieces
and you create many pawn islands as we
shall see in this game
so here we are going to stop and wonder
what should atoms do in this position
our first thought might be taking on f6
but that would help black get
his structure corrected so it's not
necessarily the best move
in these circumstances
what else can white do
and this is the moment what really makes
grandmasters slash super grandmasters
think
do i really have to react to your move
of f6
now the lower the level of the
competition
the more likely the player is just going
to take on f6
and just go over the flow but
mickey adams who's been a top 10 for a
long long
time knows that there is no rush in the
game of chess
so just when knight c3 takes
p takes c3 and the whole point is if f
takes e5
you can capture on c6 bc knight takes e5
now obviously taking on e5 is out of
question
because in an opposite colored bishop
middle game
the one with the attacking chances is to
be preferred
and it is blindingly obvious it's white
who has
the attacking chances here that's
something
that is easy to notice also this bishop
sort of an honorary french bishop is
still kind of passive on c8
making sure that this position is
somewhat better
for white black can obviously play on
with queen d6
but white should be the one pressing for
an advantage
and that kind of justifies mickey
adams's decision
not to react to fedorovsky's f6 move
bishop g4 and only now does
adam's take on f6
and here black decides to take with the
bishop however e takes f6
could come to mind as well bishop takes
f6
and again here we will have to stop
for a second just to observe the
situation
white has a much much better position
why white only has
three pawn islands meaning he only has
to tend
with a somewhat weakened a2 pawn which
is
by the way very hard to reach for black
on the other side of the board black has
to deal with
four pawn islands
that means black will have to tend
with all of them and make sure all of
them are defended
plus this king on g8 is a little bit
exposed
and can run into some danger via queen
b3
and some pressure on d5
so just by observing you can tell
that if anyone's better here it has to
be white
on the other hand it is black who has
more active pieces
white has to contend with this pressure
and black can hope for some active play
in phase and with the idea of e5 in the
future not quite right now
but in the future seeing these threats
and seeing that this pin is rather
annoying he went on and played bishop e2
a very sensible if somewhat passive move
now it is passive however it does solve
all of the threats and like dissolve all
the threats that fedorovsky set up
no longer is e5 an option
and actually queen b3 becomes a
possibility
as black no longer has threats like
bishop takes f3
let's say if you go here black can't
take on f3
and the pawn structure and the pawn
doubling compensates
for the fact that i played an active
move
so bishop e2 is very much sensible
typical
positional move by mickey adams in d6
and now respectfully asks todorowski's
bishops
to leave the premises
bishop f5 queen d2
sometimes the simple move is the best
just connect the rooks
and set up threats like bishop f4
and oftentimes in these positions
black is not worse because there's
anything
substantial is or is there like a big
threat
there isn't like a big threat going on
here but the fact is
it's just difficult to formulate a plan
that does not create another weakness
so black would love to play e5 but in
that case
you are actually creating a weekend d5
pawn
combined with a somewhat exposed king
on g8 and you have trouble on your hands
say something like rook d1 white should
be
a little bit better if not by a lot
so black just plays rook d8 rogue d1
and mickey knows for sure that black
is struggling for choice and oftentimes
grandmasters
in these cases don't rush they actually
give their opponent a little bit of a
push so they can reach time turbo phase
where they can take advantage
of their positional advantages plus the
problems that the opponent already faces
so rd1 is a typical move just
strengthening the position
and just waiting for black to show his
hands
a6 bishop f4 but the fight
is in reality still going on
over the e5 square
queen a3 and this is the moment
where even though he has a better
position you still have to find a plan
of your own
so this is again one of those critical
moments
you have to stop observe and find the
right move
by the way black did play sensibly so
far
if you would try to go play c4 you would
fall into fedorovsky's plans
he hopes that you would go there because
in that case
his pieces would come alive and there
would be
some sort of counter play for black
so c4 might be a good move but would be
rather double-edged so
white would be looking for something
that gives him a free hand to attack
and not much counter chances for
the defending side
and for that here's the big move h4
and these are those little moves that
these high class players make and
everybody
is in awe when we see them
because it feels so illogical you just
played h3 not
long ago and now you go h4
how comes why did you do that well
adams is setting up this pawn storm of
h5
and if he manages to take on g6 he will
get
very good play against this king on g8
with black really not having any counter
play against it
rookie 8 h5
and black here kind of lashes out
but i'm not quite sure if it's the best
choice he did play e5 here
but as we talked about it this is
somewhat detrimental
with the king getting more and more
exposed in an open position
however we do see that black will get
some active play
because of e5 the e i take c5
takes takes bishop takes rook takes e5
now naturally you do not want
too many pieces to be exchanged but
because there's some clear targets in
black's position
it actually works in mickey adams's
favor
bishop f3 pressing on d5
queen d6 now rookie one
rook takes e1 would still lead to a
tough position
for black because the pawn
can any moment arrive on h6 setting up
not only threats against d5 so there
could be rookie 5 coming
which is by the way a move immediately
winning the pawn but even the more
strategical h6 is an idea
where you will combine your threats
against the d-pawn
and potential queen g7 mate
patterns and when you combine these
threats that can be
very very annoying and i'd say that
white has
a hefty advantage if not decisive
so queen d6 is played saying i will give
up the pawn
but at least i can coordinate and in
this sense is a very
sensible and practical choice by
fedorovsky
take stakes but you don't have to ask
mickey adams to take the pawn
twice he does so king age eight
here comes the nail in the coffin
h6 now this king is not feeling
comfortable
okay
okay
so 8 6 and
now the position is a little bit
uncomfortable
for black because this king is basically
still mated
and you're also down a pawn not a fun
thing to have
should be 4 c4
just stabilizing there is no
need to rush this position b5
queen e2 b takes c4
and believe it or not bishop takes e4
and mickey adams wins the game because
of the h6 pawn
takes so here the game ended black
resigned
because if rook takes d1 queen takes d1
takes
queen d8 mating
and obviously queen e8 runs into queen
takes e8
checkmate and just to mention something
more exotic queen a1 queen g7 would also
wrap up the game
so that kind of shows how powerful the
h-pawn
can be but that is not the only game i
wanted to show
from mickey adams but the game that he
played against
the german talent
vincent kamer who was a sensation
when he qualified for dortmund and
the granca championship not long ago
so this is part of the series
of atoms winning five games in a row
versus grand master opposition so this
is the game between adams versus
vincent kymer e4 staple of atoms he was
most of the time an e4 player so he
sticks his
weapons and this is what he's going for
d4 d5 now not long ago i've
been reading a book about mickey adams
and his prodigy years and i was
surprised to find
that he was a fan of playing the karo
khan
in his teenage years which sort of
shocked me i always thought of mickey
adams as
a spanish player but it turns out he
played the french
but as every french player eventually
they turned into a caracon player where
they realized the bishop is a little bit
stronger on
f5 so e5 bishop f5
and the irony is that it is
tamer who's playing the carl khan
versus adams and not the reverse case
by the way that is not really surprising
as
it is well known that k-mer works with
the legendary peter laiko who was
and still is a big fan of the carl khan
h4 incidentally h4 did feature
in the match between kramnik and lako
h5 c4 now bishop g5 has been
all the rage with very aggressive play
for white
giving up upon with bishop d3
but c4 is a move and
has been a little bit overshadowed by
the short variation that's been popular
in our recent times we take c4 bishop c4
e6 knight c3 knight d7
now in some respects this has
some bits of similarities to
isolated pawn structures white spawns
are a little bit loose
and somewhat weakened however
in exchange for that white has lots more
space
and black has to maneuver around that
knight e2 should be seven knight g3
now black decides to play bishop g6
for a good reason because if you go here
knight takes f5 e takes f5
and after queen b3 you will face
problems on b7 and f7 and you wouldn't
want that
so bishop g6 the sensible decision by
vincent keimer knight e4
so here mickey adams is slaloming the
knight
to e4 threatening knight d6 jumps so
bishop h4 is basically out of question
knight 986 and here again we have to
stop
and observe first and foremost
whenever you're trying to study an
opening you need to understand
the underlying concepts now what white
is playing
for is center control and
really good piece play the bishop on c4
is excellent the knight on e4 is
threatening to infiltrate all the time
so all of those pieces
are excellently placed the big question
is
what to do with this bishop on c1
and that's the moment when you'd ask
yourself
would you consider this an open position
well you'd say
somewhat it is somewhat of an open
position
but is it more closed are there outposts
how many outposts are there actually
there are plenty of outposts
black has two opposed that he could go
for
the d51 and the f51
is there any prospect for this bishop on
c1 not really
we could use it sometimes for bishop g5
and sort of facilitate the idea
of getting an id6 in but in that case
there's knight f5
and black should be doing fine
then that kind of boils down to mickey
adams's choice
bishop takes h6 this bishop is useless
and black would occupy important
outposts
so we don't want to see any of that rook
takes h6
queen d2 knight b6 should be two
so now the position is roughly balanced
at the moment
because flank has a solid grip
all over the d5 square however is a
little cramped
and doesn't have as much of a free
movement of pieces
as white does and d5
bishop f3 just making sure that knight
is well defended
queen b6 g3 typical mickey adams making
sure there's nothing hanging
also creating a nice little square for
the bishop
on castle short castle and suddenly
we get a sharp metal game
king b8 rook d1 rook h8
just coming back that book wasn't doing
too much
so kymer decides to let's draw that rook
rook c1 bishop e4
knight e4 g6 and this is
somewhat of a concession
black could have tried to play some like
bishop f5
and just wait with the action at least
wait for mickey adams to
show his hands but decides to take on e4
which possibly bobby fischer would frown
at
because you wouldn't want to give up
your bishop pair
if you don't have to g6 and
kymer sort of builds a defensive
formation
and hopes that it'll hold up
rook c4 rook d7 and again we come
to critical position number two
what should white do it's an opposite
kite
opposite side castling position so often
times you could consider
going e3 and b4 in these type of
structures
however this position is so closed
that it might not be enough for you to
win
so mickey adams mixes it up a little bit
and goes knight c5
trying to facilitate the attack with b4
a4 black took
dc queen c7
and again a nice little move and twist
by
adams goes queen e1 defends the pawn
and sidesteps any kind of trickery
that could happen on the d file
queen d8 b4
g5 and to be honest with you i'd say
that
white should be a little bit better why
even though black has a very nice knot
on d5
white's bishop puts pressure along the
diagonal
and also does some defensive task on the
other side
so white has just an easier way of
playing this position
so mickey took on g5 in g5 rook h4
just stifling this attack
and slowly but surely these pawns are
about to start running
on the queen side with black
not really having an easy way of
breaking through
on the king side himself king c8
a4 knight e7 a creative idea
by kymer he is trying to reroute the
knight
and is brave enough to venture with his
king out to d7
but we'll see how good that is luke
takes d7
king takes d7 b5
if you go for it you've got to go for it
now
knight g6 b takes c6
and here kymer says hey king e7
i am not afraid of no ghosts
i will take on e5 start rushing down
with h4 and i will have counter play
however
mickey adams comes up with a very nice
very nice idea in this position so it's
mickey adams to move
and shine
boom goes mickey because
he realized that you've got a queen and
knight
attacking or getting close to my king
but if you're not mating me
your pieces are relatively far from
my pawns so if you go somewhere like
here
you will run into my pawn storm
and you're just going to be in big
trouble
you won't have enough time to stop these
pawns
so here's knight e5
queen e4 and people forget how important
centralizing is in this scenario what
was most important is
just to make sure that there isn't any
counterplay going on and when you have
the queen on e4
not only do you support these pawns
and you have ideas of pushing those
pawns
you also take away any queen h1 ideas
and stop any queen d1 queen d5 checks
cameraman knight g4 queen f3
just over defending the f2 pawn
queen h2 king f1 queen h5
cold blooded queen c6
stepping out of any of those trickeries
on h2s i mean knight h2 is
not an issue anymore and once this king
will gallop away
from those dangers actually knight g2
can even go back
white will be just winning
knight e5 check king f6
check can you have five queens
and again you can see that mighty queen
taking away that all important square
queen h1 check king e2 in f3
d1 check and the king walks away
and here kymer resigned because queen c3
runs into queen c2
check and there's a queen exchange and
black is
lost and that kind of
concludes this session on
adam's wins in the bundesliga
hope you enjoyed the spider-man's
fantastic
technical play hope to see you next time
until then
take care all bye
you